hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of Dylan Doris a b-rabbit
challenge it's an England versus Daniel
dubov and I think lost his match
yesterday - dubov and now he needs a win
in this match to force a third match so
similar to Hikaru situation against
Magnus and if you haven't seen the match
I'm now going to announce the result of
the second match between Hikaru and
Magnus so close your ears if you don't
want to hear it
Hikaru won the second match so the first
game that we've shown was a great
victory for he Carl and then the third
game's the the three games that followed
ended in a draw so he called won the
second match and tomorrow we will give
the third match between the two of them
but now I think needs to do the same to
force a third match against du Bois and
this is a game one of their match and
it's really a brilliancy one that your
friends wherever they are will will
definitely enjoy so without further ado
let's check it out I think with the
white pieces opens with c4 so the
English opening is on the board we have
Knight to f6 and the g3 serve out that I
think your prepares the finger to the
light square bishop we have c6 by dubov
preparing d5 - of the g2 d5 and now
Knight to f3 biding and here dubov goes
for the c4 pawn Saudi captures on c4 and
now just castles by being we have Knight
B to d7 continuing development and night
to a3 now of course now Dean wants to
win back his pawn and just continue
developing naturally where he will have
a very nice control of the older central
squares so might the beasts X for the
moment to do both defense the c4 pawn
and Queen c2 adding another attacker to
the pawn lubob defends it once again
Bishop to e6 and now Knight to e5 adding
a third attacker to the point and also
there are some very sneaky tactics with
Knight characters on c6 followed by
Bishop characters and here now if you
want to add like maybe if you want to
add another defender to opponent with
Queen before then you can go into
something like characters captures and
captures with Chuck give up the night
for two pawns and after let's say the
check is blog then you capture the roof
so it's you grab two points and the rook
for two pieces which can be can be
played for white so black usually does
does not allow this so instead dubov
goes for h5 which always goes for where
he plays white or black and now of
course his ideas he wants to play h4
bust open the Kings side and used the
rook to attack dings King
so ding of course goes after his pawn
neither a captures on c4 with Knight
captures Knight captures and now h4
continuing the attack and dings King and
now Knight back to a5 and this has all
been played before it's nothing new the
night will be much safer there also now
you have insane pressure on the c6
square by the knight Bishop and the
Queen but Duval just continues his
attack each character's and g3
we have h cactus and g3 and now this
position has been reached before in 2016
11 are inverses of Wesley so were so
played looked the c8 and Wesley lost
that game to 11 but here we have Queen
to c8 instead now Queen to see it is a
new move in the position so already has
a move 12 we have a completely new game
where do what is kind of inviting Knight
captures and c6 for example captures
captures and then if Queen captures and
c6 you just win the game of course you
cannot go for this because you also lose
the rook so after Knight captures and c6
you would have to play something else
like go for the trade here with the
better page 3 or something like that
however dingos for rook to d1 not
interested in doing anything
you know rash for the moment so du Bois
just continues with his attack Bishop to
h3 now of course Du Bois wants the
capture here and play Queen to h3 and
finish off dings King and of course if
you if you allow this then there's just
no defense Raquin to H 1 will be
checkmate as the rook also helps out
with with the attack if F reaches Queen
captures your followed by checkmate so
nothing to be done there so after Bishop
to h3 ding it declines the trade he goes
Bishop there 3 and he says I'm just
gonna continue the game I'm not
interested in any of your barbaric
attempts on the Kings side so g6 Du Bois
now prepares to bring in the bishop into
the game for the King to safety and so
on
ding does the same would be for he wants
to play a for Bishop to be to bring the
rook into the game and so on so rush up
the g7 by dubov and Bishop to b2 by dink
and now King to F
the king will be much safer there and
also add some protection to the bishop
if the knight moves and let's say this
the diagonal opens up ending continues
playing on the Queen side with a four he
is preparing b5 with night the h7 by
dubov now preparing Knight to g5 to go
for the bishop on f3 and ding just
continues playing on the Queen side he
goes b5 now of course just the
threatening to win some material here
and the dubov continues with the attack
and the King side so it's like they're -
they're playing two separate games doing
is playing positionally and the Queen
side while dubov is going for his
all-out barbaric attack on the Kings
side so Knight the g5 puts pressure on
the bishop and here dingos B captures on
c6 and remarkable but B captures and c6
a blunders the game completely so I
would ask you to pause the video here
and try to find the winning idea so if
you want you can but I'm actually gonna
ask you to do it in two moves so if you
think you're ready for you can do it now
but I'm also going to ask you to move so
for those of you who were able to do it
now really congratulations on spotting
the entire sequence but for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop captures on e5 so just
grabbing that Knight Bishop captures on
e5 and now only now Knight captures on
f3 so there is no night to recapture
here we have E captures on f3 and only
now feel free to pause the video and
finish the game for black while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting the
inevitable mate and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy the show it's Bishop to
g2 incredible stuff this is what to do
both planned out with this whole Queen
to c8 new move idea it's just remarkable
and we're after doing saw this it was in
this position unmoved 21 that dinkler
and resigned the game and Game one of
their second match goes to Daniel dubov
here here we resigned because everything
just loses terribly for example if you
capture the rook Queen h3 and there is
no defense against Queen h1 checkmate
whatever you play Queen h1 under extra
moisture commit and
other than that let's say you capture
the bishop still the same Queen h3 check
you have to go to g1 and now Queen - h1
is checkmate and other than that if you
don't want to capture here or capture
here you could try and block the Queen's
route - maybe h3 by g4 but also doesn't
work now just Bishop captures on f3 and
there again is no defense against rook
to h1 checkmated the bishop covers these
squares so you once again have to
capture the rook and then it's just
Queens you for check King f1 check King
e1 and Queen 2 G 1 will be checkmate now
yes I know your your friends at the bar
in the library are incredibly impressed
but they should be for for having such
such a great friend that knows games
like this to show them so really
remarkable stuff a duel really really
has some crazy stuff prepared at home
and this was just this was just out of
this world
taking down being in 21 moves like that
but it was it was a really weird game
this one a duo playing on the kingside
thing playing on the Queen side like you
know
no one knows what what the other guy
wants but yeah now I do go do what he
wants and in the end this is how it
happened so I'm not I don't know if I
will be able to show any more games
since tomorrow I will be really busy I
will not be in my apartment and I have
to travel somewhere so I don't know if I
will be able to show the 3rd game
between course and a Nakamura a third
match but I will show it at some point
when I get back home and there is no
third match of course for ding because
the second game from the madding also
lost and the third game was drawn so
dubov is the first finalist over DeLand
or Savi rapid challenge and tomorrow we
will find out who will join him he
called or Carlsen so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Luke Garrett Joseph Conrad Anthony
Falzone at the entry to H and the Joseph
Sullinger for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see soon continuing the coverage of
the Endora Sahabi rapid challenge
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all I will
see you soon and heaven
the rest of your day